kelly ripa skips Wednesday's live with
Kelly and Michael the first show since
Michael Strahan announced he's moving
over to Good Morning America today it's
building it for Kelly and Ana Gasteyer
how you doing I'm great how are you I am
good I'm good I've been in the news
lately
I hear that et has learned that this was
not a plan to day off for Kelly a source
telling us quote she was blindsided by
the news that Michael was leaving after
yesterday's broadcast that source adds
that Kelly might actually take the rest
of the week off to cool down Michael did
praise his co-host at the end of the
episode and I've learned so much from
her and she's just been an amazing
influence on me and this has truly
changed my life to be here with her
Kelly I thank you I love you and
everyone else here at live and a source
inside the taping tells et Michael
called it a quote hard day for everyone
during a break
ét sources say there has been tension
between Kelly and Michael over the last
four years as well as between Michael
and the show's executive producer
Michael Gelman now Michael Strahan will
stick with the show for a few more
months before moving to GMA as for who
will replace him we hear Anderson Cooper
and Neil Patrick Harris are the
frontrunners for the job